so i want to uh take a second for you to
explain
exactly how this works because i think
there's a lot of people who listen to
this
who uh they've heard of yield farming
like the terminology
they have how it works so kind of just
walk us through exactly what's happening
when people are doing this
yeah uh so first i'll just say
mechanically here's
there's a lot of different versions of
it um i'm just gonna like
talk about sort of a really simplified
version of it and you can put as many
knobs on it as you want
but at its heart what is it you build a
product
and uh it's a product people can use
um you know maybe it's a borrow lending
protocol maybe it's a dex
um whatever uh
let's for now say that it's a borrow
lending protocol that's where this all
started
um and what you say is all right i want
a lot of people to be borrowing and
lending for my protocol right
and what do i mean by borrow lending
protocol something like compound or ave
where
you can basically it's you know put in
ether and take out usdt or whatever you
know
there's sort of like a bunch of of
accepted tokens and you can lend
some of them to the protocol you can
borrow other coins against it
um and then other people can borrow the
coins you're lending out
and you're paying each other interest
for this um
i so um
see you want to incentivize growth in
your project
and you want to intensifies people to
start using it
building on it integrating with it um
and so what you do is you say all right
first of all all the revenue is going to
go to this token
you know you create a token it's the
equivalent of it you know an exchange
token a protocol token whatever
um and you say all the revenue for my
projects going to this token
you know with compounders comp um and
what we're gonna do is for the next
three months we're just gonna every day
airdrop a thousand tokens on everyone
who's using the platform
which is proportionally however much
you're using it so however much you're
borrowing
plus lending out you know that's how
many points you get
and then this thousand these thousand
comp tokens just get divided evenly
between all those people
um and i
what happens then is you know a lot of
people go to use your protocol because
they want to get your token for free
so they start borrowing or lending um
and
they get your token you give up most of
your tokens or some or
i mean it depends on the project um and
they get yield and what yield means here
is basically like
you know they're putting up you know a
thousand dollars of capital
and every day they're getting one dollar
of of the token air drops you know and
so they're getting 10 bips a day
you know on their capital just literally
putting it there and lending it out
and the yield is coming in the form of
the protocol token that's being
airdropped on them
and the vision is now all of a sudden
all these people whose borrow lending
protocols have your token
they want yours to win they want to
build on yours they're aligned with you
um and they provided value by
providing liquidity to your protocol you
know by providing coins for people to
borrow
and so all that's great and helps you
out you help them out you're aligned
that that's the theory behind it and i'm
sort of like
you know taking sort of like the
positive light the optimal version of
this and ignoring all the bad [ __ ] that
happens
okay so when people are doing this uh
just to summarize
the whole idea is to incentivize users
to adopt
my product or my network over another
one and therefore basically i pay
uh some rate of return for them adopting
that
right that's right over another one or
over just doing nothing
but yeah okay the interest i think
is uh or the return on some of these i
think is where uh kind of especially
people who come with the traditional
water like wait
what is going on because yeah you know
the return can be a thousand percent
right or you know these crazy crazy
numbers so kind of talk through a little
bit
uh i'm assuming that you you believe
that like that's not very sustainable
and will kind of get commoditized down
but maybe not
yeah that's a really good point and and
and
that is where a lot of the [ __ ] starts
to get
weird is that when someone says that
they have an interest bearing
product for you you know like let's just
say get rid of crypto right so it's like
i got some bonds you know
they're like i don't know corporate
bonds or something and they're going to
pay you interest each year and like
great what's the interest of like six
percent a year
sure like all right you know that's a
number that i
find plausible you know i'm sort of like
is that better or worse than putting in
the stock market
like i don't know maybe it's a little
worse a little safer or whatever
anything between like one and 15 percent
a year
is sort of like normal land and crypto
interest rates are higher
um there are a lot of ways to think
about this but just generally crypto
interest rates are like
20 a year roughly so in crypto you have
something that pays 20
a year and it's actually kind of
reasonable you know
there are a lot of people who pay 20 a
year for capital there are a lot of
people who loan capital at
percent a year whatever um
so okay anywhere between like five and
thirty percent is like plausible in
crypto but as you said some of these are
a thousand and a thousand
is equivalent like it's just like that's
a ridiculous number right like like no
one ever pays you a thousand percent a
year
right and why is that well first of all
everyone would do it
also why are they paying you so much
money where is it coming from
like this way too much like you could
you could have said
a hundred and i would have been amazed
at it like a thousand
like that that's ridiculous so it's sort
of your thoughts like this has to be a
scam
like this is the like you know send one
bitcoin to us and we'll send you two
back
type scam right um and
and what's actually happening there is
i well mechanically what happened was
yeah they're dropping the tokens on the
users and just do the math
you know they're giving away half of all
their protocol tokens the next two weeks
and uh that's a quarter billion dollars
worth of tokens are given away
and you know there's optimistically
going to be
a billion dollars locked in this
protocol
using it so then you have 25 over a
couple weeks that's where you get these
insane numbers from
and there are sort of a few ways of
thinking about this the optimistic way
is like yeah time horizons are shrinking
they want their protocol to do well soon
so
they're like we're not going to give it
to the next you know pass out these
tokens over the next two years let's
just do over the next two weeks
why wait so yeah it's a ton of yield for
two weeks
if we're giving away mostly value the
protocols to users and that's that's the
trade we're making in return for getting
a lot of users
and i it's a little weird because people
should be putting a [ __ ] ton of money in
like that should be drawing
a hundred billion dollars out to make
the return more reasonable right like
um that's sort of the optimistic take
the pessimistic take is like
it's a scam and or it's not
really a thousand percent a year and
what does that mean
here's an easy way to give it an insane
yield you just take a token
and every day you double the number of
tokens you mint another
entire new set of them and air drop it
on the current token holders so yeah
you're given 100
today but obviously the price is
crashing like it's just a hyperinflating
token
you're not actually giving out value
there and so another thing that might be
happening
is that the tokens price is actually
crashing just as fast as it's paying you
so you don't make money for for doing
this um
or maybe it's a scam they're gonna steal
all your money somehow
and so those are the pessimistic takes
are these just like the new icos
yeah i mean they're not exactly the new
icos like
i i mean there there's differences and
everyone will
come up with like their own
you know sort of reasons for why they're
different
and not not structurally but just in the
sense of
you know using a new mechanism for
capital markets and incentives and and
kind of um
you know acquiring users you know icos
was one version
this seems just like a second yeah and
that's not passing judgment on good or
bad it just
is what it is right and and i think in
the end my answer to you is
closer to yes than no you know my answer
is sort of like
yeah these kind of are the new icos like
that's actually not a bad way to think
about it
and whatever there's you know a lot else
going on there obviously
it's not that but but yeah at its heart
he's
there a lot of resemblances to icos and
it also feels like
um there's this game going on like
in my opinion uh there's people who uh
i'm probably closer with that would say
you know bitcoin is the only thing
nothing else matters all this other
stuff is you know frankly garbage and
like you know whatever
um what i think is interesting though is
if you say okay like that is one view of
the world and uh probably more right
than wrong in terms of bitcoin having
immense value
kind of moving forward but there's also
this
like kind of thought process of wait a
second there's a whole bunch of
financial engineering and craziness
going on here
if you're a pure capitalist and you say
i have no emotional connection
whatsoever to any asset
uh you can make a lot of money right and
drive a lot of returns so yeah if you
almost come out like from a hedge fund
perspective where
fund says i don't care what the ass said
it's all numbers on the screen and
basically i'm just looking for things i
can buy low that go up and then i can
sell higher and
you know make a return that seems to be
the people who are thriving in this
environment yeah
and you know they're sort of i know i've
retweeted this a number of times
although it's not actually my
quote i say group cms uh
it's a cool firm i who
i coined this but you know sort of do
you want to be right or do you want to
make money
and like you know there's sort of this
thought of like all right
you can use your words you can say
whatever you want you know
and and i'll be here making money
because i'm gonna go yield farm
and you're not gonna yield farm and like
you know we'll see who wins
i know what winning means but i guess
about who's gonna end up with more money
you know that that's sort of like maybe
what you're getting at there which is
like
put aside all the like moralizing and
all the philosophical
aspects of in the projections and just
say like can you make money yield
farming
the answer is yes you can make money
you'll farm it you make a lot you don't
have to lose a lot i mean it's
you know if you just yield farm scams
then you're just gonna lose all your
money
and um if you don't understand that
tokens
can crash and that their prices can move
even if they're not scammed
then you're gonna end up yield farming
and all the pools are probably gonna
crash
so it's not like you can only make money
doing it
but there are were ways that were
actually just not that risky